outre ces vins de crue renommée la terre
beaujolaise est aussi terre de bien
manger dans cette entreprise performante
de saint-romain des îles on fait tout
pour assurer la notoriété de bonnes
cochonnailles sur le marché intérieur
français et à l'étranger par le biais de
l'exploitation il faut dire que son pdg
fin gastronome s'emploie à diversifier
les produits dont la fabrication est
assurée par un matériel moderne et dans
les meilleures conditions matérielles
moderne que cette feuille certainement à
l'intérieur du beaujolais qui arrosera
la viande de porc devant servir à la
confection du bose nouv le dernier né de
la chaîne de salaison
pour affiner peaufiner un suprême délice
monsieur gauche 9 prg ensemble dans s'il
vous plaît laly de beaujolais la suite
mon dieu que c'est bon
voyons notre émoi ce produit à 7 la
couleur d'abord ne change rien à
l'intérieur c'est la chair des saucisses
ou et couleurs est un petit peu plus
accentuée un petit peu rouge accentuée
et puis après ils allient pénètrent
lentement alain carion du saucisson et
donc accentuer la couleur bon et alors
est ce que l'on pourrait penser que vous
vous faites une concurrence à ce produit
noble qu'est le beaujolais lui-même le
vin puisque maintenant on peut manger
une saucisse en hausse passant de boire
du beaujolais missionnaire oui mais
toute la différence est que le
beaujolais ce bois alors que
l'opposition se mange
voici narrer l'histoire de jésus
saucisses en 07 avec aussi pour nouveau
compagnon le seigneur de ses terres en
grande et belle aux robes cuisses
généreuses
le soc au beaujolpif